hi we're kyle mooney and back bennett
and we're here today with buzzfeed
to read your thirst
time to get a bucket of cold water
because it's about to get steamy
are you at all worried that it's gonna
get like a little too sexy for us
i am i'm a little nervous it's not like
a sexual interaction between the two of
us
you know reading these thirst tweets but
it's kind of like sort of like a little
bit of a foreplay type thing
yeah i guess i i was thinking this was
gonna sort of be like foreplay between
us
kyle mooney kiss me challenge what does
that mean
that could be the opposite of a third
tweet if they're like it's a challenge
to kiss him like
who who would ever be willing to i don't
think that's i don't think that's what
that's what i think that's what it means
like who like
it's a challenge to kiss you because
like it's like a hard thing to do
not because it's like hard to get to you
it's easy to get to but like for them to
suck i didn't mean it upset you know
just the first one and
it kind of feels like you're already
coming down on me i did not mean to come
down on you
at all i just we're just supposed to
comment on that
i thought it was kind of like you know
like the ice bucket challenge
everybody does it like oh it would be
cool if there was a oh
mooney kiss me challenge yes that's what
she wants when did beck bennett get hot
and perfect
seriously though when probably when i
was a baby
they i will say it is funny to me that
like it is kind of insinuating
that there was a time when you were
definitely not hot and very
imperfect i think that's fair
i think you're hot and perfect are you
serious but when did that happen
i don't know when would you say it
happened january
me too i'm in love with kyle mooney and
would love to make hot hot passionate
friendship with him
that's really sweet man i think that you
know friendship is one of the sexiest
things out there
i don't know what hot passionate
friendship entails but um
it sounds horny like you know where like
nothing's really ever happening but
you're like
really aggressive like handshake
may i have a kiss yeah uh yes
yes you can thank you for asking thank
you not for
just doing it keep one you're gone um i
like
uh kisses no tongue just uh and no
saliva on the lips just dry lips
wrinkled like duh kyle mooney is my
boyfriend
and my dad that's definitely kinky this
is a situation where i feel like i need
to get in touch with this person because
i don't know that i was fully aware of
that
that you have a child but that sounds
like kyle that sounds like the kind of
movie i know
that he has a kid that became his
boyfriend and he didn't know about it
yeah that sounds like kamiano too
i wish the news weren't so terrifying so
i could just focus on how hot beck
bennett is as putin
yeah even though the news is terrifying
you can
look at my bot to give you yourself a
break from from a hard week
is it the quarantine or does kyle mooney
have a surprisingly sexy body hashtag
snl at home
it's definitely not the quarantine
brother i got a little spelt over the
corn i i i
i wasn't taking in as many calories i
think during the quarantine i like your
body
i like the hair that you have on it and
you you're very confident in it which is
one of the sexiest things
well i've always kind of wished that all
this terrifying news could stop so that
i could focus on how hot you are as
putin
everybody keeps saying that this is a
thirst post
expressing my immense lust and adoration
for
our talented king yes beck bennett
bb is my white man of the day month
year decade century millennium etc
i would like to invite him to do
whatever he wishes with this information
hopefully it's me yeah
that's so nice i do you like it that
it's bb as my white man
and i'm i'm fine with that if she wants
to
consider me white uh kyle mooney is hot
yes explain how he's hot i just know
that he
is hot it is a funny one where it's like
he's not
actually hot but he's uh listen also i i
don't think i'm hot i'm not
i think you're hot i think you're a sexy
man i think you're sexy too but
this is getting a little hot between us
yeah sometimes you don't want to explain
how somebody's hot you know
it's like you don't want to explain a
joke you just want to enjoy it for what
it is even though for you i think
it's clearly your johnson yeah beck
bennett's legs are the eighth and ninth
wonders of this world
i appreciate that yeah my thighs are big
old
ham hocks they're they're chunky monkeys
they're thick ricks and they're
they're short and stout wide strong
little skinny minis what kyle mooney
dressed up as
jackson maine is my very specific kink
hashtag snl
oh i forget jackson venus he's
the character in uh star is born oh yeah
can you do your texan for us real quick
oh man uh how does that song tell me
tell me something
girl i've been ruining winter old town
world
and everyday isn't red and do
i do you think you get it
that was amazing thanks why are you so
close i just wanted to get a better look
at you
oh thanks man uh beck bennett could
smash me any day
nice yes any day any it doesn't matter
even if i'm having a rough day if i'm
hanging out with my parents
thanksgiving dinner passover dinner with
my wife's family
kyle mooney has good legs they should be
on my shoulders
nice that seems like a uh not a
piggyback
what would you call that so like the
game of chicken in a pool or something
it seems like this person just really
wants to kind of hoist me
more like a celebration i think it would
be really cool if like you and i were
just like hanging out and walking around
the studio and you had like some
short jeans on and you were on my
shoulders and we were just like walking
around
casually saying hi to people beck
bennett big sexy
in all caps sometimes you can't argue
with when something's in all caps
the internet has spoken back bennett big
sexy the internet's always right what if
we were all talking about kyle mooney's
big
energy yeah what would that be like kyle
came in and he was farting all afternoon
god he stayed but his
big energy was so great that nobody
cared
well it's nice to hear that you know the
assumption is i guess i have some
confidence is
is what i get out of it is that right
no i was messing with you just doing a
video
yeah just for just for buzzfeed to kind
of like mix it up a little bit man
again no worries take me away
beck bennett's thick thighs we're kind
of in the leg
portion of the of this machine oh yeah i
kind of see like a little
little music video about my thighs and
like um like my thighs are cradling that
person
and they're like yeah it's sort of like
when austin powers lost his mojo
right enough with the austin powers
losing his mojo dude
imagine pete davidson and kyle mooney
spit roasting me
what is a spit roast well i think it's
spit roast is like when you like roast
the pig
like at a luau like i think he dagged
and tied as well like an apple in their
mouth
with their like hands tied and i
imagined it immediately where you and
you and people were wearing like
uh thongs and big boots it's nice to be
seen
back bennett iconic thick yeah
true again coming with the thickness i
normally like
big bearded guys but i would suck kyle
mooney's nerdy
they called you nerdy i guess i i fall
into the nerd
camp is that right yeah i mean you're
really picking it apart here
i mean she's just trying to tell you
that she would suck your nerdy
she's right actually my my dick is nerdy
it's got like a little pair of glasses
on it
and a pocket protector i knew it and
what about the balls
i i don't have any nsfw i want to lick
back bennett's nipples
i think that is yeah i was gonna say i
feel like sucking my
nerdy was maybe not safe for work yeah
it's fine i mean you know it's
fun and they're out there like we put
them on on the tube
oh what was that i was i i was thinking
about licking your nipples
those are some thirsty thirsty tweets
this was fun doing with you man
i will never forget don't forget to
watch snl
yeah don't forget to watch snl this
season live coast to coast
siena nbc guys stay thirsty
cnnbc guys stay thirsty